so in your blog post zeroth principle
thinking good title you ponder how do
people come up with uh truly original
ideas
uh what what's your thoughts on this as
a human
and as a person who's measuring brain
data zeroth
principles are building blocks
first principles are understanding of
system laws
so if you take for example like in
sherlock holmes he's a first principal's
thinker so he says
once you've eliminated the impossible
anything that remains however improbable
is true whereas dirk gently
the holistic detective by douglas adams
says
i don't like eliminating the impossible
so when someone says
from a first principal's perspective
and they they're trying to assume the
fewest number of
things within a given time frame
and so when i after braintree venmo
i set my mind to the question of
what single thing can i do that would
maximally increase the probability that
the human race thrives beyond
what we can even imagine and i found
that
in my conversations with others in the
books i read
in my own deliberations i had a missing
piece of the puzzle
because i didn't feel like uh over if
yeah i didn't feel like the future
could be deduced from first principle
thinking
and that's when i i read the book zero
uh a biography of a dangerous idea
and i i think a really good book by the
way it's
i think it's my favorite book i've ever
read it's also a really interesting
number
zero and i i wasn't aware that the
number zero had to be discovered i
didn't realize that it caused a
revolution in philosophy and and
it just tore up math and it tore up i
mean it builds modern society but it
it wrecked everything in its way it was
an unbelievable disrupter and it
was so difficult for society to get
their heads around it
yeah and so zero is of course the
representation of zeroth principle
thinking which is it's
the caliber and consequential nature of
an idea
and so when you talk about what kind of
ideas
have civilization transforming
properties
oftentimes they fall in the zeroth
category and so
in thinking this through i i was wanting
to find
a quantitative structure on how to think
about
these zeroth principles and that's so i
came up with that
to be a coupler with first principle
thinking
and so now it's a staple as part of how
i think about the world in the future
so it emphasizes trying to identify the
lands on that
word impossible like what is impossible
essentially trying to identify
what is impossible and what is possible
and being as
how do you i mean this this is the thing
is
most of society tells you the range of
things they say is impossible is very
wide
so you need to be shrinking that i mean
that's the whole process of
of this kind of thinking is you need to
be very rigorous in in
trying to be trying to draw the lines of
what is actually impossible
because uh very few things are actually
impossible
i don't know what is actually impossible
like it's the joe rogan it's entirely
possible
i like that approach to uh to science
to engineering to entrepreneurship it's
entirely possible
basically shrink the impossible to zero
to very small set
yeah life constraints favor
first principles thinking because it
it enables faster action with higher
probability of success
pursuing zeroth principle optionality
is expensive and uncertain and so in a
society constrained by resources time
and money
and a desire for social status
accomplishment etc
it minimizes zero principle thinking but
but the reason why i think zeroth
principle thinking
should be a staple of our shared
cognitive infrastructure is if you look
through the history of the past couple
thousand years
and let's just say we arbitrarily
we subjectively try to assess what is a
zero level zero level idea
and we say how many have occurred on
what time scales and what were the
contextual settings for it
i would argue that if you look at
alphago
when it it played go from another
dimension
with the the human go players when it
saw alphago's moves
it attributed it to like playing with an
alien playing
go with uh with alpha beating from
another dimension
and so if you say computational
intelligence
has an attribute of introducing zero
like insights
then if you say what is going to be the
occurrence
of zeros in society going forward
and you could reasonably say probably a
lot more than have occurred
and probably more at a faster pace so
then if you say
what happens if you have this
computational intelligence
throughout society that the
manufacturing design and distribution of
intelligence is now going to heading
towards zero
you have an increased number of zeros
being produced
with a tight connection between humans
computers
that's when i got to a point and said we
cannot predict the future
with first principles thinking we can't
that cannot be our imagination set it
can't be
our sole anchor in this situation that
basically the future of our conscious
existence 20 30 40 50 years
is probably a zero
so just to clarify when you say
zero you're referring to basically
a truly revolutionary idea yet something
that is
currently not a building block
of our
shared conscious existence either in the
form of knowledge
uh yeah it's currently not manifest yeah
in what we
acknowledge so zeroth principle thinking
is
playing with ideas that are so
revolutionary that we can't even
clearly reason about the consequences
once those ideas come to be
yeah or for example like einstein
that was a zeroth i would categorize it
as a zeroth principle insight
you mean general relativity space time
yes yep yep
that basically that building upon
what newton had done and said yes also
and it just changed the fabric of our
understanding
of reality and so that was unexpected it
existed
we just it became it came part of our
awareness
and the moves alpha go made existed
it just came into our awareness and so
it
to your point there's this question
of what do we know and what don't we
know
do we think we know 99 of all things or
do we think we know
0.001 of all things and that goes back
to no no
no unknowns and unknown unknowns and
first principles and zero principle
thinking
gives us a quantitative framework to say
there's no way for us to mathematically
try to create probabilities for these
things
therefore it would be helpful if they
were just part of our standard thought
processes
because it may encourage different
behaviors in what we do individually
collectively as a society what we aspire
to what we talk about
the possibility sets we imagine
you